hello everybody and welcome to the third
and final lecture in this series of
Stinson lectures by John Mishima liberal
dreams and international realities
that's the name of the forthcoming book
is it I'm not sure that that will
finally be the title but some working
title of the forthcoming book from Yale
University Press in the Stenson lecture
series and today he is going to be
speaking about the case for restraint
welcome John thank you and as I said
yesterday and on Monday there's a great
pleasure and an honor to be here and I
feel actually somewhat sad that this is
my last lecture because as you know I
like talking and this is a fascinating
subject and I could give at least five
more lectures on it the first night I
talked about the roots of liberal
hegemony and that talk is those of you
who were there no was really mainly
about liberalism did not say much about
international politics and then last
night I talked about the false promise
of liberal hegemony and liberal hegemony
of course is all about international
politics and I made the case that since
the Cold War ended the United States has
pursued a policy of liberal hegemony and
it's led to nothing but trouble and it's
been very costly as well and what I want
to do tonight is make the case for
restraint and this is an argument that
what we need is a more restrained
foreign policy and the way I'd like to
proceed is I'd like to ask the classic
start by asking the question does
liberalism encourage restraint and I'd
actually like to go back to sort of
Monday night's lecture and just talk a
little bit about the nature of
liberalism and make the argument that
inside of liberalism there is an
important strand
that would push a great power to pursue
a policy of restraint not a policy of
liberal hegemony and then answer the
question of why that strand of
liberalism seems to lose out to the more
expansive strand then I want to talk
about restraint what exactly it is
talk about realism and restraint because
I'll make the argument that restraint is
basically a realist foreign policy then
I want to talk about nationalism and
restraint and as you remember from that
first talk I said that what I was really
interested in doing in this book was
talking about the relationship between
liberalism nationalism and realism so
here you see the realism in nationalism
coming into play to challenge the
liberalism and then I want to talk about
where the United States is headed today
that's well that's where I will end so
the first question is does liberalism
itself encourage restraint and there are
actually two strands in liberalism
there's a Universalist strand in a
particular strand and what I have done
in the past two lectures is hammered
away if the Universalist strand this is
a slide excuse me that I used the other
night and that those of you have been to
either one of the previous lectures is
very familiar with and my argument is
that when you focus on the individual
and you marry inalienable rights to that
individual you get a Universalist
ideology right because every person on
the planet has this set of inalienable
rights and you're focusing on
individuals not countries or nations
you're focusing on individuals and they
all have these rights so you see that
powerful Universalist tendency and I've
made the argument of course that what
that does is inexorably lead to a
foreign policy where you try to spread
liberal democracy all over God's little
green acre but inside liberalism there's
also a particular strand
liberalism's particular a strand is
based on the fact that it's impossible
to agree on first principles and I
stress that at great length in the first
lecture liberalism is based on the
assumption that individuals cannot reach
agreement on universal truth there are
always going to be disputes so it's
impossible to agree on first principles
and therefore it's imperative to adopt a
live-and-let-live political order this
is why liberalism privileges Liberty and
powers this is what I love about living
in liberal America right there's a great
emphasis placed on giving people a lot
of space to lead their lives the way
they want to and we emphasize things
like tolerance and peaceful conflict
resolution
these are wonderful values it's kind of
modus vivendi liberalism and then they
say shouldn't this basic logic apply to
relations among States just as it
applies to relations among individuals
shouldn't we as liberal America tolerate
the fact that China has no interest in
being a liberal state and prefers to be
an authoritarian state or if someone
wants to create a fascist state why
should we care according to liberalism
you're not supposed to be able to say
that liberalism is better than fascism
or authoritarianism or communism take
your choice according to liberalism
right people can't agree on first
principles and therefore you want to
give people plenty of room to live their
life the way they see fit
why doesn't the same argument apply to
States why aren't we more tolerant
if you go back to the Universalist
strand there's no tolerance there
remember that Michael Doyle quote I put
on the screen yesterday well Michael
bull hell basically says any non liberal
or a liberal state is at war with its
people move you know you believe that
and you're off to the races right but
again there's a particular strand as
well as a Universalist strand but what's
clear is that the Universalist strand
wins out and the question is why is that
the case and I'm not a hundred percent
sure but it's probably because liberals
tend to believe that they have
discovered at least one important truth
you're basically violating their core
precept that you can't reach agreement
on first principles liberals are
basically saying that liberal democracy
is the best political order and there is
no acceptable alternative but you're not
supposed to be able to say that but
that's certainly the way they act well
this is to say any of you look carefully
at liberalism one could argue that
really it should lead to a policy of
restraint a modus vivendi type foreign
policy but of course it doesn't okay
restraint what's restraint putting
forward the argument that the United
States should adopt a policy of foreign
policy of restraint first of all it's a
realist foreign policy and one of the
really difficult tasks that I face and
giving this presentation and writing
this book is that most Americans hate
realism and they love liberalism and
anyone like me who comes along and says
we should adopt a realist foreign policy
and abandon a liberal foreign policy
really has a tough sell in front of him
or her okay but restraint is a realist
for Impala
see and I'll explain why that's a good
thing whether you agree with me is
another matter
restraint also pays significant
attention to the power of nationalism a
theme that I've beaten hard in the
previous two lectures policy restraint
basically calls for getting out of
business of spreading democracy or
promoting democracy around the globe and
especially at the end of a rifle barrel
my view is if you want to spread
democracy around the world the best way
to do it is to be the city on the hill
right have a model democracy at home and
then you can expand to other people what
you think the virtues are of liberal
democracy and then leave it up to them
to decide what to do but you don't want
to purposely try to spread it with
aggressive policies that's what we're
strength is basically all about okay
realism and restraint the essence of
realism realism focuses on great powers
not minor powers for realists
the states that really matter are the
great powers in the system and the only
time that minor powers really matter is
when those minor powers are adjacent to
great powers Korea and Poland are two
good examples right Poland matters
because it's sandwiched in between
Russia and Germany or the Soviet Union
and Germany or way back when
austria-hungary Germany and Russia
Poland matters Korea matters because
Korea's sandwiched in between Japan
China and Russia the three countries
that have the worst geographical
location in the world are Korea and
Poland and now I think you could
probably throw in Ukraine right these
are countries that really are in the
wrong location
right in their minor powers they matter
but by-and-large
fine Lord realism to the theory that
focuses on the great powers and it
focuses on the balance of power right
the argument that realists make is that
those great powers care greatly about
how much power they have relative to the
other great powers in the system
realists as you know pay little
attention to domestic politics realists
basically treat States as black boxes it
doesn't matter the most real estate is a
democracy or an authoritarian state the
structure of the international system in
the real story basically forces most
states to behave in similar ways right
and you can see where Americans would
hate a theory like that because
Americans believe that the world is
populated by good guys and bad guys and
we're the good guys and other states
that look like us are also good guys but
everybody else is a bad guy it's kind of
consistent with liberal agenda right and
that's why we want to make all of the
states in the world liberal democracies
because they then all look like us and
if we're the good guys and everybody
looks like us that means you have a
planet that's populated by good guys and
then a planet that's populated by good
guys you can't have anything but happy
outcomes right that's the liberal story
the realist story is it just doesn't
matter right and the realist story is
that the big enchilada is in the system
we're going to compete with each other
and this occasionally going to fight
wars with each other now very important
to understand that there's a distinction
between defensive realists and offensive
realists don't talk about the defensive
realists the defensive realists are very
interesting lot their basic message is
the destruction of the international
system encourages States not to go to
war with each other
States they say should concentrate on
defending the balance of power not
trying to change the balance of power
it's a really quite interesting argument
and the key reason for this is balancing
behavior if the three of us are great
powers and I start to accumulate more
power these two other states are going
to get very nervous they're going to
form in a military alliance and they're
gonna try and contain us the defense of
realists would say look at what happened
to Napoleonic France they got greedy and
they got crushed by a balancing
coalition of five European states look
at what happened to Imperial Germany
look at what happened to Nazi Germany
look at what happened to Imperial Japan
they got aggressive balancing
coalition's formed and they were crushed
the Germans should have just sat still
the Japanese should have just sat still
they were in the catbird seat no need no
need to be aggressive and when you are
aggressive you get crushed so you have
defensive realists like my good friend
Charlie Glaser who wrote a famous
article called realists as optimist
right so you could see why these guys
like restraint right because realism
leads to no war here's Mark Trachtenberg
another good friend of mine historian
first class historian these are some
quotes from an article that he wrote
realism is at heart a theory of peace ok
power is not unstable it's impractical
idealism that's liberal hegemony that
leads to endless conflict serious
trouble developed only when states
failed to act in a way that made sense
in power political terms right so the
caves from restraint from a defensive
realist
point of view right really leads to a
remarkably peaceful world now as many of
you know their offensive realists out
there in the world like me who think the
defense of realists are wrong I believe
that the structure of the system is not
benign it encourages States to compete
with each other for power right States
constantly want to improve their
position in the balance of power and for
me the ultimate goal is to be the
hegemon in the system and sometimes
states will go to war to achieve that
end I do not believe like Mark
Trachtenberg or Charlie Glaser or Ken
waltz or Steve an average Jack Snyder
all of these defensive realists that
structure is behind I have a much more
Hobbesian view of the world still even
offensive realists like me right would
argue that if you follow the precepts my
theory you'll have a less warlike world
than you will following the precepts of
liberal hegemony why is that the case
three reasons here's the first first
realists are only willing to fight in
limited areas of the world liberal
hegemonist what a fight everywhere
because they're interested in spreading
liberal democracy all over the planet
there is no area of the world that is
unimportant from a strategic point of
view for a liberal hegemonist they don't
prioritize there are no priorities for a
realist that's not true at all during
the Cold War the United States was
interested in competing with the Soviets
all over the planet realists said this
is redic
Kilis there are only three areas of the
world that matter for the United States
Europe and those days we used to say
Northeast Asia and the Persian Gulf
those are the three areas you fight and
die the rest of the Middle East
no Africa no Central Asia no Southeast
Asia no it's no accident that every
realist except Henry Kissinger was
opposed to the Vietnam War
this is strategically an important area
the only fighting areas were their great
powers or in the case of the Gulf a
critical resource oil but again for
liberals a very different story reason
number two realists understand even
offensive realist like me understand
that balancing behavior takes place I
believe that if China continues to grow
in terms of economic and military power
and it begins to assert its influence in
the East China Sea the South China Sea
over Taiwan and in other places on its
periphery there'll be a very powerful
balancing coalition that forms against
it and they'll be limits to what the
Chinese can do this is the defense of
realist argument I think they take it
too far they don't understand that
sometimes states don't balance
effectively and there's opportunities to
acquire power on a part of the aspiring
hegemon but the point here is all
realists understand basic balancing
logic liberals don't because liberals
believe that realists like me and even
realest like mark Trachtenberg are
products of the 17th century
we're old think we're dinosaurs so they
just think you can just gets back to my
discussion of NATO yes a they think that
you can March NATO right up to Russia's
borders and it's not going to matter to
the Russians realists say this is crazy
you March NATO up to Russia's borders
you're gonna have big trouble no
surprise that you had a war over Georgia
in August 2008 and then you have a war
Ukraine starting in February 2014 basic
balance of power logic but liberals
don't believe in balance para logic and
what I'm saying to you here is that if
you understand realist logic it makes
you much more cautious and that gets to
my third point it's not something that's
peculiar to realism but it does tend to
be peculiar to realest realest of
basically Clausewitz Ian's realest for
the most part pay a lot of attention to
military affairs they read claws bits
they take them very seriously they study
military history liberals don't
and when you read claws vets in your
study military history you understand
you're in the realm of unintended
consequences anybody who goes to war
thinking this is going to be easy to
weigh all these boys and girls in the
Bush administration and even outside the
Bush administration thought when we went
into Iraq in 2003 these people live in a
dream world it's just not the way
international politics works you've got
a war it's basically a crapshoot this is
the realm of unintended consequences
incredibly complicated enterprise war
how it all turns out hard to predict of
course sometimes you go because the
potential benefits far outweigh the
costs and you think the likelihood of
success is quite high but but realists
tend to be very cautious the point I'm
making to you here is you have this
group of Defense of realists who believe
that the structure is remarkably benign
so if you adopt a realist foreign policy
you get no war then you have realists
like me who don't accept that view who
think that realism does lead to a rather
Hobbesian world but nevertheless even
for
realists of my strike you'll get a less
aggressive foreign policy than you get
with liberal agenda because again with
relish you get priorities respect for
balancing behavior and respect for the
fact that war is an enterprise that is
hard to predict realism and too big
Fiasco's in my lifetime I could not
think of any to greater Fiasco's than
the Vietnam War and the Iraq war as I
said to you before every realist opposed
the Vietnam War the two principal thorns
in my opinion and LBJ is hiding during
the run-up to Vietnam were Hans
Morgenthau and walter Lippmann both
card-carrying realus george kennan was
opposed to the war ken waltz was an
adamant opponent of the war before the
war went south in 1968 he was an
opponent in 63 64 65 and with regard to
the Iraq war
virtually every realist again except for
Henry Kissinger opposed the Iraq war
thought it was a boneheaded idea to
invade Iraq so the point that I'm trying
to make to you is if you adopt a realist
foreign policy it's clearly not an
idealist foreign policy there's no
question about that but you're going to
get a lot less murder and mayhem in the
system and you're not going to end up
with a militaristic state called the
United States of America you're going to
get a restrained foreign policy which i
think is a good thing now if you could
convince me that liberal hegemony works
then I'd have real problems arguing with
you because it works and even though the
costs may be greater the benefits are
really wonderful but it doesn't work it
leads to disaster so I say from a
realist perspective we need a more
restrained foreign policy bottom line
real ins not recipe for peace but it's
more peaceful than liberal hegemony now
let me turn to nationalism and restraint
remember I have a double-barreled
shotgun here realism and nationalism
keypoint you want to keep in mind about
nationalism
it makes conquest very hard and that has
consequences - consequences you know
went away those consequences out and
then I want to talk about the domino
theory in Vietnam which some of the
older dogs in the audience will remember
first of all because conquest is hard
that means the United States should be
very wary about trying to conquer other
states right and second you want to
remember that the ability of your
adversary to conquer other states is
also greatly limited by nationalism so
what I'm saying here is if you
understand nationalism you understand
the power of nationalism it's going to
make you very cautious about going on a
rampage we're trying to conquer other
countries and it's going to make you
less worried when your adversary starts
to try to conquer other countries
remember what I told you about my views
on Afghanistan in 1979 when the Soviets
went into Afghanistan in 1979 virtually
everybody in the world I operated was
apoplectic oh my god they're on the
march right they've just conquered
Afghanistan right it's were they gonna
go next probably Iran who knows my view
was exactly the opposite they've just
jumped into a giant quagmire this is
wonderful news wonderful news so so the
point is you don't want to jump into
Vietnam if you're the United States and
if the Soviet Union decides that they
want to jump into Vietnam by the way the
Chinese you remember the Chinese Chinese
and the Soviets help the Vietnamese beat
us in Vietnam we lost in 75 then
79 the Chinese invaded North Vietnam and
they got their snouts whacked surprise
of surprises first it was the French
then it was us
then it was the Chinese that's a place
what stay at it right and if you're
dealing with an adversary that decides
it wants to go into Vietnam he'll be my
guest
right good luck so let's talk a little
bit about the domino theory the domino
theory goes like this it says that
communism is like liberalism is a
universal ideology and what happens is
that if the Soviet Union succeeds in
Vietnam then Thailand will fall
Indonesia will fall Singapore will fall
Japan will fall Korea will fall
eventually the dominoes will fall in
Europe and eventually the big Domino the
United States will fall right and again
it's based on the notion that that one
conquest is easy and two when you
conquer those other countries what will
happen is that other countries will just
bandwagon because first of all to find
communism very attractive the fun
communism very attractive for
ideological reasons but secondly they'll
understand that they're going to be
conquered next just to take this out of
context the domino theory and at how it
applies to the Bush Doctrine remember I
said yesterday the Bush Doctrine called
for knocking off regimes in the Middle
East and replacing them with liberal
democracies and the first place on the
train line was Iraq but Iraq was not the
last place we were going to do Syria to
Iran when the Israelis caught wind in
January 2002 we wrap up the war in
Afghanistan or at least so we think in
December 2001 and then in early too
- we're getting the shotgun loaded to go
into Iraq the Israelis catch wind of
that they sent the high-level delegation
to Washington and they say are you crazy
Iraq is not the principal threat in the
region Iran is and the Israelis want us
to do her in the administration and the
neocons on the outside say relax we're
going to do it ran after we do Iraq or
if we do Syria after we do Iraq by the
time we roll up Iraq and then roll up
Syria the Iranians will throw up their
hands and jump on the bandwagon right
that's the domino theory and again it's
not surprising at all because you see
very powerful military actor of the
United States that can conquer States
easily and that has this political
ideology liberalism that it believes him
so it's domino theory logic but back to
the Cold War we were worried stiff that
the Soviet Union would conquer this
country conquer that country and do it
very easily and then this transnational
ideology called communism would help
facilitate the fall of all the dominoes
including the United States at the end
of the story okay so how does this
affect us behavior we fight in Vietnam
right Reid Fred Logan vols
terrific book on Vietnam called choosing
war which is the best book I've read on
why we went into Vietnam one of the
principal reasons we went into Vietnam
is almost everybody in a position to
power at that point in time including
huge chunks of people in the public
believed in the domino theory they
believed that we had to stop him in
Vietnam because if we didn't dominoes
would fall right what's the fate of the
domino theory the domino theory it's a
joke right
any good realist understands that the
domino theory is a joke first of all
conquest is really difficult you know
what happened to the Soviets in
Afghanistan you know it's at the dozen
Afghanistan you know what happened to
the British in Iraq you know what's
happened to us in Iraq you know what
happened to the French the Americans and
the
Chinese in Vietnam nationalism is a real
obstacle to conquest so the idea that
you could have easy conquests throughout
Southeast Asia which was what we were
thinking about in the 6465 period not
going to happen and then with regard to
the ideology this transnational ideology
communism communism is no match for
nationalism you run nationalism up
against communism nationalism will win
every time
have you noticed where the Soviet Union
is gone right it's broken up into its
series of constituent nation states
remember the sino-soviet split oh by the
way China communist state invaded North
Vietnam communist state oh by the way
why did they do that because Vietnam
communist state invaded Cambodia
communist state mmm doesn't sound like
that transnational ideology had all that
much peel right nationalism very
powerful for us and of course we first
went to war in Vietnam I'm young enough
old enough to remember this as young at
the time but the argument was that the
reason the North Vietnamese were so
fearsome and they were fierce nobody
went into combat against the North
Vietnamese had any doubts about that
these were tough hombres the reason they
were so fearsome so they said was
because they were communists but with
the passage of time we came to
understand that was fundamentally flawed
line of argument they were so tough
because of nationalism and that's what
made conquest so hard so my point to you
if you had to do the Cold War all over
again this is how I'd do it
I'd be relaxed I wouldn't worry about
the spread of communism hardly at all I
certainly would never invade a country
like Vietnam I stay out because the
domino theory doesn't work and I would
argue that if we become engaged in an
intense security competition
with a rising China which I think is
likely to happen if China Rises I think
the last thing we want to do is start
invading countries for fear of a domino
theory like effect as a result of
Chinese aggression and if anything if
the Chinese get into the business of
invading countries that they think they
can conquer and facilitate some of some
kind of domino effect on their part not
going to work so what I'm saying to you
is that both nationalism and realism
push the United States toward restraint
restraint on the other hand is anathema
to advocates of liberal hegemony I've
tried to make that point clear in the
first two lectures so realism points in
one direction and liberal ham gemini or
liberal for our policy points in the
other direction okay
where is the United States headed what
is the future hold I think there are two
possible future world's first future
world is multipolarity and that's a
consequence of China's rise and the
continued resurrection of Russia most
people I know think that this is the
direction that we're headed in most
people think we are now entering
multipolarity that we're transitioning
out of unipolarity it's hard to measure
polarity but even if you don't think
that we've reached multi polarity at
this point most people believe it won't
be long before we do and then the other
possibility is unipolarity
and this is the case where China
stumbles badly and Russian power
declines over time and this is the
argument that we will be more
powerful in the year 2050 relative to
everybody else than we are now you all
understand just to give you a feel for
this that America's three principal
competitors from the 20th century Russia
/ Soviet Union Japan and Germany think
about world war one world war two Russia
Germany Japan all are declining powers
largely for demographic reasons all of
these countries are going to undergo
significant demographic decline and the
United States is in good shape
demographically the only two countries
that are really in good shape
demographically over time er India and
the United States the Chinese also have
quite significant problems right but
there are three principal competitors
are gonna be much less powerful relative
to us in 2050 than they are now there's
only one country on the planet that can
give us a run for the money and that's
China and if the Chinese were to stumble
just humble really badly I'm not saying
that's likely I don't think it's likely
but if they were to stumble really badly
we would be more powerful relative to
every other state in 2050 than we are
today and we would be free to pursue
liberal hegemony again okay okay so
multi polar future if China continues to
rise
Russia's resurrection from the dead
continues it's the end of liberal
hegemony just over this is the point
that I have made on a number of
occasions you cannot have liberal
hegemony in bipolarity or multipolarity
you can only have it in unipolarity
because if you're in a bipolar system or
you're in a multipolar system where the
United States is one of the poles
the United States has to pay attention
to the other great power or powers and
it has to engage in balance of power
politics it cannot afford to pursue a
liberal foreign policy in any
significant way maybe somewhat on the
margins but the essence of a great power
is foreign policy in a bipolar or multi
polar world is almost always going to be
realism so if we do move into multi
polarity liberal agenda is gone
what if we don't what if we have a
unipolar future as I say it's a it's a
fertile ground for more liberal hegemony
more liberal hegemony and therefore the
$64,000 question is whether or not it's
possible to sell a foreign policy of
restraint in the unipolar world to a
country like the United States to the
sole pole Uncle Sam is the sole Paul
thoroughly liberal country we've tried
this once before we're back in
unipolarity can we sell a policy of
restraint this is the montero template
that I put up yesterday this is from
Nuno's book on unipolarity and you
remember I pointed out didn't you no
argues that in a unipolar world the unit
Paul has three options the Unipol can go
home because it's so powerful and secure
number two it could stay involved abroad
and use its power to maintain the status
quo where 3 it could stay involved
abroad and use its power to alter the
status quo engage in serious social
engineering and of course as I said
yesterday and you folks all surely
understand
the pursuit of liberal hegemony is
number three and restraint could be one
or two and I would argue that restraint
could be somewhere in between one and
two
number one is basically isolationism
isolationism
is a policy of restraint and given the
three options that nuno puts on the
table I think number two is also a
policy of restraint so you can just have
a foreign policy with the United States
pretty much stays where it is but
doesn't try to reshape the globe in its
own image for my purposes I prefer
policy that's somewhere between numbers
one and two I don't want to get into
this in any detail but I'm not an
isolationist so I don't want to you know
practice come home America but at the
same time if I had my druthers in a
unipolar world I would not stay involved
abroad in every region of the world I
pull back in a lot of regions I'd
certainly pull back
American forces from Europe but anyway
the point that I'm trying to make to you
is that a policy of restraint actually
in practice involves something along the
lines of one or two in Nuno's template
or somewhere in between but that's what
we're talking about now are there any
reasons for optimism optimism about the
possibility of adopting a more
restrained foreign policy and
unipolarity there are some reasons first
of all the decision to initially adopt a
policy of liberal hegemony is different
than the decision to continue it at a
critical decision point or the decision
to go back to it after a brief hiatus
and my argument is that it's almost
impossible to prevent a liberal unit
Paul
hasn't tried liberal hegemony from
trying it right because the the the DNA
of a liberal hegemony is such that it's
very hard to resist the temptation to
reorder the world in ways that you think
are of great advantage to you and all of
humanity so I think the initial decision
to adopt unipolarity is almost
impossible to combat adopt liberal
hegemony is almost impossible to combat
but a subsequent decision to do it once
you've run the experiment you've seen
what the costs are and what the benefits
are and the likelihood of success are I
think you stand a pretty good chance of
of combating it there are other factors
too there's actually a little public
support for liberal hegemony
it's basically an elite driven
enterprise you want to remember that
George W Bush got elected in 2000
running against nation-building and
arguing that what we have to do is pull
in air horns and not try to reshape the
globe George W Bush as a presidential
candidate was very critical of of the
Clinton administration for being far too
ambitious
on the foreign stage and he was elected
and then he became the most I think the
most ambitious foreign policy president
in our history he was a liberal
hegemonist par excellence read his
second inauguration address read a
number of the speeches that he gave at
places like AEI George W Bush sounds
just like Woodrow Wilson there's no
better spokesperson for liberal hegemony
than George W Bush that may be hard to
believe but I'm not exaggerating it's
really quite remarkable but anyway he
ran as a candidate calling for restraint
go back and read Condoleezza Rice is
famous P stand for
in the january/february mm you of
foreign affairs was she who was very
close to george w bush lay down his
foreign policy it's all there and then
you remember barack obama barack obama
got elected on the platform that he was
going to pursue restraint and he of
course spelled and he basically admitted
he failed in his interview with jeffrey
goldberg in the atlantic in his last
year in office
but he was interested as a candidate in
restraint and he got elected and george
w bush got elected and as you heard me
say yesterday donald trump donald trump
ran against liberal hegemony really hard
he challenged almost every element of
the strategy and he got elected so the
public has no problem electing leaders
who are opposed to liberal gemini and
are in favor of restraint but the
problem is once those leaders for an
office they seem to go in the other
direction but anyway the public could be
mobilized the u.s. also has a rich
history of restraint stephen kinzer has
this new book out terrific book you
should read it if you have an
opportunity that deals with the first
great foreign policy debate in the
united states regarding whether or not
we should go abroad and intervene in the
politics of other states in a big way or
we should basically pursue a policy of
restraint and it's a debate that takes
place after the spanish-american war in
1898 it's a huge debate and Kinser lays
it out in great detail and of course the
restraint is lose but Kinser makes the
point that if you look at the history of
debates about american foreign policy
over the course of the 20th century you
see that the restraints are there in
force in almost every key decision point
and actually in the 1930s when the
united states was an isolationist
country the restrainer 's were in the
driver's seat i don't think that was a
good thing by the way
I think isolation was not isolationism
was not an American
interests and I think it's fortunate
that we got into the war but the only
point I'm trying to make to you here is
that restraint is in the form of
isolationist were very powerful at that
point in time and after World War Two
there was a huge debate between
restrainer isolationist again and people
who wanted to use American military
force broadly moreover I do think that
states learn and they have agency we've
seen what happens gets back to my
earlier point this is not you know
liberal agenda is not something that we
haven't tried before we've tried it now
we've run the test we've run the
experiment and there's no reason that we
can't change things and then I would
argue there's an emerging counter elite
of restraint in this country they're
growing numbers of people who are
disenchanted with what the United States
has been doing and who think it would be
smart for us to pull an air horns to
pursue a more restrained foreign policy
so I think for all these reasons there's
a good chance that restraint could carry
the day nevertheless the majority and
the foreign policy establishment The
Blob is deeply attached deeply attached
to liberal Gemini and they'll do
everything they can to stymie restraint
my good friend Steve Walt has recently
finished a book manuscript that deals
with the blob and its love of liberal
hegemony and he makes a somewhat
different argument than I do but it
reinforces the point that the blob has a
deep-seated interest in combating
restraint and continuing to pursue
liberal Jemmy but Steve's basic argument
is not like mine mine is that liberalism
as an ideology
right provides a very powerful impetus
for pursuing liberal agendas Steve's
argument is that it's basically a jobs
program for the liberal elite right all
these people in Washington have jobs
that depend on having the United States
run the world so that you know they can
occupy very important peace positions in
the State Department and the Defense
Department and National Security Council
and if you begin to shrink all those
institutions right and you don't have
military bases all over the world and
you're not interfering the politics of
every country on the planet right people
are going to start losing jobs and you
know lots of people graduating from Yale
who want to become part of the foreign
policy establishment you know that right
you want to go out and help run the
world and if the United States pulls in
its horns what are you gonna do you may
have to go over to graduate school and
get a PhD in political science oh my god
or in history all right you know you'd
rather go to law school or something or
go to the Kennedy School get a degree
and then go out and run the world right
it's a jobs program it doesn't
contradict my argument you understand
John has made a very different argument
here over three days
John's argument focuses on liberal
ideology and says that that ideology is
deeply wired into the American body
populace especially the elites and
therefore we pursue this policy
liberal hegemony because we are in a
unipolar world that's the argument steve
has a different argument but it
reinforces my argument that his argument
again is it's basically a jobs program
for the elite so they'll fight mightily
to prevent us from pursuing a policy
restraint my bottom line final slide I
think China is likely to continue rising
and I think liberal Germany will be off
the table and the really interesting
questions down the road will have to do
with the us-china rivalry so when Ian
invites me back
talk the next time there will be little
discussion of liberal hegemony and much
discussion of basic realpolitik behavior
in East Asia that's what I think is
likely to happen so we won't have to
worry much about liberal agenda but the
problem with that is that the United
States then ends up with a peer
competitor China do we want that I think
I'd rather have you know polarity and
run the risk of returning to liberal
hegemony rather than see China turn into
a peer competitor but again if trying to
becomes a peer competitor liberal
hegemony goes away in the event the
world resort's back to unipolarity
which I'd prefer to see over continuing
rise of China for good realist reasons
it's hard to say whether restraint will
carry the day I don't know I think there
are some good reasons for optimism but
there also some good reasons for
pessimism so on that note I will end and
I will gladly take questions from the
audience
[Applause]
the u.s. goes renewable energy that goes
away we see this already import/export
balances frankly only this country's
made up of Russia Armenia deskah Mexico
/ Spain and of course overseas
possessions of the u.s. disassociating
let me ask you let me ask you a question
when you say when Europe learns how to
defend itself with it what does that
mean what Europe Europe is not a country
it's a series of countries isn't it
aren't those US isn't it is it you're
comprised of a series of sovereign
nation-states head is Europe defend
itself I'm always puzzled with
very long ye stay run the risks of the
the end will have to arm themselves
okay let me take your question first on
the Persian Gulf and then go to Europe
on the Persian Gulf if we reach a point
where oil doesn't matter
right we're for some reason or another
there are other ways of fueling these
economies then the Persian Gulf is not
going to matter okay because the United
States cares about Europe and East Asia
because that's what the great powers are
but obviously there's no great powers in
the Gulf there's oil in the Gulf but in
your scenario oil doesn't matter much
anymore then it's not going to be of
great strategic importance so I think
we're in agreement on that regard to
Europe where I think there's a bit more
disagreement between the two of us look
I think there's two good reasons for
staying in Europe my defense of realist
friends why we're talking about who I
was talking about before they want to
stay in Europe because they believe it's
important to preserve the peace in
Europe and their argument is that if you
take the United States away and NATO
collapses right you'll have the Russians
and the Germans competing with each
other the Germans and the French will
not trust each other the British will be
separate from the states on the
continent and if you have a war in
Europe right that will mean the United
States will have to come back in and
that's what economic consequences for us
so it's better just to stay there and in
Joseph Geoffrey's terms remain as the
American pacifier
we are the underpinning the underpinning
of stability we the Americans are the
underpinning of stability in Europe and
let's just keep it that way
okay so that's one way of thinking about
Europe but it assumes of course that
you'll have war among European states
that the EU is not enough to
that by itself that's not my view my
view is that the United States should
only go into Europe with military force
if there is one state that threatens to
dominate all of Europe be that Imperial
Germany in 1914 Nazi Germany in 1939 and
the Soviet Union in 1945 right the
United States has to come in to make
sure that none of those not three
countries dominates all of Europe and
when I look at Europe today there's no
state that threatens to dominate all of
Europe Germany as I said is depopulating
it's getting weaker and weaker
I believe Germany has about 19 million
more people than France and Britain
today if you look at I think it's UN
demographic projections out to the
pardon okay I'll give you that but I do
think you're wrong but I'll give it to
you ah let's go back to here let's go
back to the year 2050 the demographic
projections put France Britain and
Germany all the same size
demographically it's because the Germans
are declining so rapidly right so
Germany is not a problem Russia is not a
problem
Russia's of declining great power in
large part for demographic reasons so
why are we in Europe from my point of
view again my friends who want to just
preserve the peace there we are a
peacekeeper they'll stay but I'm not
interested in preserving the peace I'm
just worried about a dominant power in
the region the area I would stay in is
China
excuse me as East Asia because of the
Chinese right that that's the argument
but so I'm not that interested in
staying in Europe but other people are
yes yes yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I would just change the word curly
in the realm of ideology to purely in
the realm of politics but which i think
is completely consistent with what you
said it's a great question and I haven't
thought much about it but I think that
what I'm saying is that it really is all
about politics because you're raising
the question about the differences
between liberal hegemony and realism
right and you're saying is there an
economic factor that discriminates a
from BAE and I think the answer is no
what makes me nervous about this is
because I'm a political scientist and I
focus on geopolitics
I almost instinctively go for the
politics and I tend to forget the
economics so I'm staying to myself as
you're asking the question maybe I'm
just forgetting the economic dimension
but I don't think so I think there's no
real economic dimension that explains
the differences between the two I think
liberalism
is really all about it's all about
spreading liberal democracy and realism
is all about the balance of power now
some people might say that liberalism
emphasizes the importance of creating an
open economic order an open
international economic order I think
that's certainly true but so to realize
right everybody agrees that the open
international order that we created
roughly from 1945 up until the end of
the Cold War and then work to maintain
up until Donald Trump was elected was a
good thing you know realists and
liberals realists and liberals didn't
fight over economic
and they didn't fight over institutions
either liberals tend to love
institutions but realists really kind of
love institutions too right so economics
institutions there's no real divergence
I think it's the politics but it's going
along here something pops into my mind
don't believe the Chinese are changing
the rules I believe that the Chinese are
interested in dominating Asia the way we
dominate the Western Hemisphere I
believe that they will ultimately try to
push us out of East Asia they will tell
you behind closed door as many of their
elites that they intend to push us out
beyond the first island chain and then
beyond the second island chain they
intend to build a blue water Navy that
can project power into the Persian Gulf
because they get 25% of their oil from
the Gulf and that number is expected to
go up to close to 30% in the next 15
years so they're very ambitious right
and this is well before I get to Africa
because I want to just I'll come to
Africa good but you raised a really very
important point about what the Chinese
are up to right and not so much in
Africa just in terms of what they're
doing more generally with regard to
using military force the key point you
want to keep in mind about the Chinese
is that time is on their side and
therefore they have no interest in
causing trouble now
the name of the game for them is just to
grow and grow and grow and then when
they become God's Ella tell all the
neighbors and tell Uncle Sam right here
are the new rules in the neighborhood
you have no choice but to obey us right
we on the other hand and China's
neighbors on the other hand have a
vested interest in provoking conflicts
and setting the rules of the road now
when the balance of power is in our
favor you understand the balance of
power is shifting against us in East
Asia so all the incentives are for us to
make it clear where we think the lines
in the South China Sea are now the
Chinese are in the other hand should
just say nothing they should speak like
good liberal Americans peace love and
dope right and then just keep that
economy growing and keep translating
that economic might into military might
like Taiwan you know the Chinese want
Taiwan back and they made it clear that
Taiwan East at at some point they're
going to take it back if the Taiwan East
don't surrender but now is not the time
for China to pick a fight over Taiwan
they do much better today in the year
2017 than they would have done in the
year 1997 you ramp it back 20 years
would not have been a fair fight over
Taiwan Chinese we were fared very badly
they'd fare quite well today but I say
wait in another 20 years
wait in another 30 years and the Chinese
are very patient they'll tell you that
30 years from now you just basically to
tell the Taiwanese they have no choice
it's all over ladies and gentlemen you
understand that this is what happened
with the British in North America you
understand that after we got our
independence in 1783 the British went to
great lengths to try to prevent us from
dominating the Western Hemisphere they
did not want to hegemon in the Western
Hemisphere
they couldn't prevent it they thought
about intervening the American Civil War
because what you do if you intervene in
this
of a war on the side of the south of
course is you get a confederacy and the
United States you have two countries
that's what they wanted they wanted to
balance the power but what happened with
the British is they reached the point
where they understood there was nothing
they could do to prevent the United
States from dominating the Western
Hemisphere and by the way they were
lucky it turned out that way because we
pulled their chestnuts out of the fire
in World War one and again in World War
two but they couldn't foresee that
anyway I would say to you I think in the
case of China given the size of that
population they have a per capita GNP
that looks anything like Taiwan or South
Korea they are gonna be so powerful
relative to us and we're taking them on
6,000 miles from the Chinese I mean for
the California coast hmm so the Chinese
are trying to sit still not do too much
to provoke their neighbors or provoke
the United States and just grow and grow
and grow now your question about Africa
Africa is an area of little strategic
significance right it's a little
strategic significance so even though
the Chinese are doing all sorts of
investment in Africa and they're deeply
involved in Africa we don't care that
much if on the other hand the Chinese
start to do that in South America you
know the Monroe Doctrine right they
start to do that in South America that
would be a very different story right so
I think we'll not have major problems
with what they're doing in Africa the
Gulf remember I told you they're
building a Bluewater Navy going into the
Gulf just while I'm on
stream-of-consciousness boat here Iran
Turkey
the Chinese are playing kissy-face with
the Iranians and the Turks the United
States is foolishly driving the Iranians
into the arms of the Chinese right don't
want to do that you're gonna want to
minimize Chinese influence in the
Persian Gulf and given our relations
with the Iranians and even their growing
relations with the Chinese don't want to
push them together same thing is true
with
Turks but that's you know Persian Gulf
port an area unless this gentleman's
view on the Gulf is correct and well I
think Russia will be a week great power
right that would be my argument I wish I
could give you simple indicators that
measure power and I wish I could say
I've done the calculations and the
Chinese will have 50 units of power will
have 49 units of power and they'll have
21 but they're above the threshold of 20
but it's very hard it's not very hard
it's impossible to do that but my basic
argument is that you will end up with
multipolarity with two big enchiladas
and one small player but still a great
power and and that will be the Russians
it may be the case that we do end up in
a bipolar world which is I think what
you were hinting at yes no yes
could you talk a little bit louder
please
[Music]
who says that I have to talk this okay
yeah let me make it a number of points
to your excellent questions when I go to
China I often posed this question to my
interlocutors I say look you folks got
hooked on capitalism and you joined the
american-led order in the early 1980s
and if you look at what's happened since
then you've just gotten richer and
richer and richer you're really in a
wonderful position and you have
benefited enormous Lee from
participating in this american-led order
moreover the Americans pay the costs of
maintaining the order right you don't
have to pay the cost and in no way shape
or form does the US military threaten
you so why don't you just sort of sit
back and relax and accept the fact that
we run the world and just get rich I
have never met single Chinese like that
argument right they'd all like that
argument now two boys one just let's
talk about economic let's talk about
institutions when you talk about the
liberal order or you're talking about
international order order is all about
institutions the Chinese not
surprisingly are interested in number
one creating new institutions that they
run the AIB fits in this category and
they're also interested in increasing
their influence in existing institutions
the Chinese ambassador to the United
States who I know very well from way
back when
he is written in foreign affairs look
what these institutions were created
mainly by the United States China had no
say in the rules and therefore the rules
privilege of the United States you all
understand when the United States
creates institutions they're set up to
privilege us others benefit too but
mainly us well the Chinese are getting
really powerful so they say we should be
able to rewrite the rules okay
and with regard to the South China Sea
you've been watching what the Chinese do
in the South China Sea that doesn't look
like a status quo power to me you look
at you watching what they're doing in
the East China Sea with regard to the
hour said Kaku Islands it doesn't look
like a status quo power to me they're
building a blue water Navy they're
spending one heck of a lot of money on
defense
right this is not a status quo power
this is a power that wants to throw its
weight around and I don't blame him one
bit you remember what happened to the
Chinese when they were weak right the
century of national humiliation 1850 to
1950 roughly you don't want to be weak
the Chinese understand this full well
they want to be really powerful they
want to be Godzilla they want to be up
here they want the Japanese down here
and they want the Americans on the other
side of the Pacific Ocean and I don't
blame them one bit
I like the Monroe Doctrine so why should
make this is my view of the Chinese
right now just with regard to leadership
you know are they going to be the global
leader you know given Donald Trump's
performance up to now it kind of looks
like that may happen if China continues
to grow and he's in power for eight
years but I would just say to you the
United States is not going to surrender
easily to the Chinese right the United
States is a jealous God and the United
States will go to great lengths to
remain the top dog in East Asia and
prevent China from dominating East Asia
and the end result is that to the extent
that you have an order in the
international system and order an
international order it's not going to be
an American dominated order if China
continues to grow the two of them
Chinese and the Americans will compete
to run that order and that's the world I
see sort of in front of us not one where
the United States dominates and not one
where China dominates and of course this
all assumes that China continues to grow
economically you said can be stopped
you mean can be stopped by the United
States a high likelihood for small wars
for maybe a low likelihood of a great
power I don't understand the last part
of the question so if we shift our focus
from sort of dallying around contain
China right what is what is Chinese
continue to do one doesn't work oh okay
I think look that if China continues to
rise as I was indicating in response to
the young woman's question I think
there's no question that the United
States will try to contain China and
then you raise the specter of now we're
talking about a great power war job
we're not talking about small wars in
the periphery I think you're exactly
right I think that containment against
China will be dangerous I can just
unpack that a bit for you if you think
about the Cold War this the central
front in Europe was the principal place
that we thought a war would break out
between the United States
in the Soviet Union but the truth is
when we used to run war games during the
Cold War we could never get a war
started in Europe and the reason is you
had two massive armies armed teeth with
nuclear weapons and nobody knew for sure
what would happen when they crashed into
each other but it was very easy to paint
plausible scenarios where we all got
vaporized and that's not a good thing so
you had no war right --mess
great paradox that underpins deterrence
which is the more horrible a war is
likely to be the less likely you'll have
that war to begin with but of course if
the war happens oh my god okay but
fast-forward to East Asia today the
United States and China the potential
points of conflict are the South China
Sea the East China Sea Taiwan you can
imagine plausible scenarios where we end
up shooting at each other we end up in a
war I'm not arguing for one second it's
likely right but I'm just building on
your point which i think is correct that
you know liberal agenda for all its
faults involves small wars
we're not that many Americans die and if
you get into a serious containment
effort against China the potential for
real trouble is great
well I don't think I don't think gonna
Toto say to this gentleman here I think
you're more likely to have a limited war
out in the water it is possible to
callate to a total war I think although
I think that's quite unlikely look I
don't have a good answer to how you
avoid war other than to say you want to
make sure you have sufficient forces to
make the other side think that they
can't start a war and and succeed at
achieving their objectives you want to
go to great lengths yourself to make
sure that you don't engage in roll back
roll back you don't want to do roll back
you want to do containment you know
there's this whole literature on the
Cold War now it shows what we did a lot
more than containment we're a heavily
into roll back which is very offensive
in nature I don't think you want to
engage in rollback this is a form of
restraint in a competition with the with
the with the Chinese so you you know you
want to do things like that but can you
be sure that you won't have a war the
answer is no and again as I said to this
gentleman here I think you know you can
paint a plausible picture of how you get
a war
in dopey I hadn't heard the term honest
and it's kind of hard to figure out what
it might mean when I hear the word in
though I think of Indonesia but
Indonesia is not you know likely to I
endo sounds like a task for Wikipedia
[Laughter]
did somebody have a question
and more places for interaction and
competition and leadership institutions
so that they were good okay how did she
push it with regret - you remind me
after I'm done with him I want to go
back and just deal with one issue was
very important that you raised but it
slipped out of my brain just say Britain
Germany when I went to you okay because
I'll forget it's early Alzheimer's with
regard to his question great question
let me just embellish it a bit he's
comparing the u.s. Soviet competition
with a us-china competition and he's
making the argument that was really
different is you have economic
interdependence right today and you had
virtually no economic interdependence
during the Cold War and he's absolutely
right
and as many of you know one of the
principal liberal theories of peace is
economic interdependence theory I've
given my talk on why China cannot rise
peacefully probably a hundred and fifty
times and probably 50 times in China and
I get three our three counter arguments
you know people come at me as always
happens in these things people come at
me and the argument that is used against
me 90% of the time is the economic
interdependence argument the reason that
John is wrong and the us-china situation
is different than a u.s. Soviet
situation is because there was no
economic independence then and there is
now so that that is the argument I'm not
gonna knock the argument downward but
differently I'm not gonna try to knock
the argument down but I don't agree with
that argument as you would expect but
that is an argument that I think is the
principal competitor but let me make
just another point because this is a
very important subject this is another
argument that you occasionally hear and
that is that the Cold War had a really
vicious ideological dimension to it
it was communism versus liberal
democracy slash capitalism and basically
what you're gonna get because communism
is not a meaningful ideology and China
is you're just going to get good
old-fashioned great power politics right
and so we don't have to worry very much
about ideology fueling the conflict
between China and the United States as
we had to during the Cold War my counter
of that which I just point out because
it ties into nationalism is that because
the Communist Party does not have a lot
of legitimacy in Beijing or in China
more generally they've begun to play the
nationalism card in a big way and their
nationalism card
centers on is they're sent to this young
woman here the century of national
humiliation the Chinese really drive
home the century of national humiliation
and who are the two principle humiliate
errs in the story Japan and the United
States and nationalism is a very
powerful force so you get into a crisis
you could have that ideological
dimension really matter
even though communism as in the Cold War
is not there I just want to say he asked
an excellent question but it slipped out
of my mind you asked whether there was
pardon no you asked the question about
whether there was anything we could do
to stop China's rise and the answer is
there's nothing we can do to stop
China's rise and I
a guy who wrote a dissertation on this
for me he actually teaches at Yale
Singapore but let me just say a few
words on this what he did was he looked
at how Britain dealt with Germany's rise
you understand that Germany doesn't
exist until 1870
there's no Germany until 1870 its
Prussia and a handful of other German
places like Bavaria and Bismarck with
three wars 1864 1866 1870 puts Germany
together and then the Germans are making
huge numbers of babies and they're
making lots of Steel so the British from
1870 forward see Germany rising and the
question is what do you do about it
right I believe the crossover point is
1905 do you try and strangle the Craig
for the baby in the cradle right and the
British not surprisingly have a huge
debate on this issue what can we do to
stop Germany's rise and given what
happened in World War one in World War
two it might have been a good idea if
they'd been able to stop it but what the
British come to conclude is given the
economic interdependence of the day the
British come to conclude that in trying
to wreck the German economy they would
do more damage to their own economy than
they would to the German economy and my
student argues that yes we could do a
great deal to wreck the Chinese economy
and prevent their rise but we would do
more damage to ourself then we would to
the Chinese so there's no way to slow
down Chinese economic growth from our
side I mean it may happen for internal
reasons in China but there's nothing we
can do and therefore the best we can do
is to contain China and then we get down
to this whole question that you and the
gentleman in the rear raised about
whether or not you can do that
peacefully and that is a tricky issue so
before we draw things to a close and
thanks professor min I just want to say
there will be a reception upstairs on
the second floor immediately following
this lecture to which
everybody's invited to continue the
conversation I've been to many lecture
series and Yale usually by the time we
get to the third lecture there's a real
question will there be an audience well
will the people run out of questions
will it sort of fade away none of those
things have happened here I think we
could have a fourth and a fifth if don't
we have another half-hour but this has
really been terrific we're all looking
forward to the book and thank you so
much for doing yeah thank you
[Applause]
[Music]